bonsoir bien 7,8 week-end dans cette
émission dédiée à vos loisirs et vos
idées sorties nous vous parlerons d'une
exposition qui se tient que mon
conservatoire des arts de montigny le
bretonneux d'un festival cajun ce
week-end à jouars-pontchartrain mais
tout d'abord donc direction le scarabée
à la verrière pour la 15e édition du
championnat inter collèges
d'improvisation théâtrale au programme
de la soirée demi finales et finale
entre quatre collèges saint quentinois
moyen de bissy elodie -
c'est sous un tonnerre
d'applaudissements que les élèves du
collège gustave-courbet de trappes ont
remporté le trophée du 15e championnat
intercollèges de match d'improvisation
théâtrale sharif membres de l'équipe
gagnante nous livre le secret du succès
c'est le mental parce que l'été soudés
on disait faut pas stresser pour se
lâcher il faut pas avoir peur des
réactions du public faire comme si
public était pas là et voilà faut pas se
prendre la tête faut se lâcher sur le
terrain pour s'amuser c'est comme ça
qu'on fait des bonnes appréciations
organisé par la compagnie déclic théâtre
cet événement intercommunal ne désemplit
pas ce sont en effet plus de cinquante
collégiens qui tout au long de l'année
participent aux ateliers d'improvisation
dans dix établissements scolaires saint
quentinois c'est un très beau moment moi
j'ai senti vraiment au fur et à mesure
que les les joueurs se galvaniser un peu
parce que ben voilà qu'on a la final à
prochaines échéances approchent
guerrière plus attaquant mais bon un bon
cru un bon niveau c'est toujours
agréable de voir les joueurs qui se
révèle vraiment en match et notamment en
finale et en demi finales puisque
l'échéance approchait une occasion de
plus pour le théâtre d'improvisation de
démontrer que cette discipline s'inscrit
dans une démarche artistique culturel
une belle reconnaissance en somme pour
ces jeunes comédiens la possibilité de
jouer dans des salles magnifiques et
d'être reconnus pour en tant que
comédien vraiment parce que c'est ça
nous parlera porte je pense que c'est
une belle reconnaissance pour eux de
pouvoir jouer dans des conditions comme
ça avec vraiment d un spectacle de
qualité qui les met vraiment en valeur
je pense
voilà et puis sachez que téléfilm 78 à
assurer la réalisation de ce championnat
un rendez vous à retrouver un
complètement en entier cet été sur notre
antenne des 6 au 8 juin se tient un
joueur qu'on chartrain la troisième
édition du festival cajun et zydeco
bonsoir mes invités viennent martine
bonsoir c'est vrai quoi nous sommes bons
soit on se perd cette venue accompagner
un instrument de musique oui vous allez
interpréter un morceau tout à l'heure
quel est le principe du festival casa
alain le festival que j'ai un ce sera le
troisième là
on a fait ça par rapport à un jumelage
la ville de jouer à gauche en train a
été jumelé en 1998 avec la ville de hama
après de la nouvelle orléans et donc on
a dans les années qui ont suivi on avait
on a eu très envie de faire connaître
cette culture et et
la cuisine et tout ça enfin la musique
donc on a eu on a voulu faire un
festival et le festival a été créé en
2010 donc ce sera la troisième édition
et savéol très complet la dépendance
vais dès ce vendredi soir à 20 heures
mais ils durent samedi à partir de 11h
je sais ça jusqu'à plus de 20 pays y
compris le dimanche il ya énormément de
groupes qui se représentent oui la
nature à seize groupes dont le groupe de
cédric et le groupe d'être cédric watson
et bijoux créole il y aura d'autres
groupes louisianais franco louisianais
disons bobigny chaud et sauce piquante
et sarah savoy et les autres viennent
d'europe voilà c'est un festival
européen américains ont pour écouter de
la musique est ce qu'on pourra danser
aussi bien sûr bien sûr il ya des stages
d'instruments il ya des stages de
cuisine il ya des stages
de musique de danse oui c'est ça et
voilà qu'est ce qu'on peut
historiquement la vidange est en train
est très liée à la louisiane parce que
il ya eu le conte de fées dépôt de
pontchartrain donc était le ministre de
la marine de louis xiv et a envoyé des
expéditions en louisiane à partir du
xviie siècle et voilà donc il ya
jumelage était louis filière 13 anciens
liens historiques et le lac de
pontchartrain a été nommé par rapport à
un nom de ce ministre
le compte de pontchartrain et la
nouvelle orléans aussi d'ailleurs par
rapport toujours au compte de
pontchartrain qu'est-ce qu'on louisienne
est une victoire pour nom il ya le lac
pontchartrain et le lac maurepas qui ont
été nommés donc d'après le nom de ce
ministre de pontchartrain au point de
ces douars de la louisiane la louisiane
oui c'était colonisé
donc
au début du
xviie siècle xvième siècle même les
européens sont allés conquérir le
nouveau monde et les français donc en
ont été ont conquis une partie des
territoires ça s'appelait la nouvelle
france à aller des grands lacs jusqu'au
golfe du mexique savent que ça fait à
peu près un tiers de l'amérique du nord
en fait à peu près on a fait à peu près
14 et à napoléon l'a vendue en 1803 et
voilà on est allé conquérir le nouveau
monde en pensant que s'est en allé en
inde et en fait c'était l'amérique
qu'est ce qui vous plaît vous culture de
la louisiane masse et
les grandes figures qui est assez
différent de la culture américaine oui
mais on se retrouve quand même un peu en
famille enfin on a la pression parce que
les premiers
l'esa a été peuplée d'abord par les
acadiens qui sont allés donc qui sont
partis dans les provinces de l'est du
canada au départ qu'ils savent les gens
venaient du poitou de la bretagne de
l'ouest de la france et après ils ont
été chassés par les anglais parce qu'il
y avait des querelles des guerres
constante entre la france et
l'angleterre les acadiens ont été
chassées en 1755 par les anglais et ont
été soit envoyé dans des prisons et ont
dû s'échapper ils ont rejoint là ce que
ce qui le sud donc ce qui était devenu
la louisiane et
et voilà il ya aussi évidemment l'apport
des
deux après l'avènement de la révolution
tous à tous les aristocrates qui ont
fait des plantations de coton de canne à
sucre
également l'apport des migrants allemand
19e siècle les espagnols louisiana et
espagnols aussi 30 enfin voilà du coup
ça sera serré qui se ressent aussi dans
cette musique c'est parti c'est un grand
mélange de deux cultures différentes et
évidemment les africains qui vont sont
venues contre leur gré et qui ont
beaucoup influencé la musique actuelle
musique12 en parlait justement il en est
question l'occasion évidemment de ce
festival qui a lieu du 6 au 8 juin à
jouarre pour certains avant de parler
avec cédric que watson de ce festival
puisque vous vous serez avec votre
groupe bijou créole ce vendredi soir et
samedi soir je vous propose de voir un
extrait d'une édition précédente du
festival cajun et cajun
mais passé
ma
oh
m
bon
alors cette équation de lydie vous êtes
en concert ce vendredi soir et samedi
soir à jouars pontchartrain
alors pour vous présenter vous êtes né
en 1983 au texas et puis après vous êtes
parti en louisiane oui c'est pas très
loin du texas s'est passé pas très loin
d'être tous là et moi j'ai grandi
c'était un petit village qui s'appelait
saint-philippe et mais ça c'est le
premier village de texas et voshix né et
j'ai grandi là bas mais ma famille nous
autres visiter ma famille on la
louisiane toute ma vie en faisant votre
famille est issu de louisiane il est à
deux cousins tas de famille là bas et
c'est pour ça nous auteurs nous aurons
passé là bas on a passé pour la visiter
mais pour que le grand monde de ma
famille mes parents et tout enfin le
gambling au casino comme les autres qui
connaît mais nous les enfants restés
dans la maison et moi j'écoutais
beaucoup la radio et j'en ai entendu
beaucoup la musique française la musique
cajun la musique créole et puis la
musique zaricot mais au texas et moi je
viens la musique à l'école c'est une
grosse affaire c'est un grand chose
parce que c'est un grand parti de notre
coutume là-bas ça fait nous a donné des
cabots et des vachers et quand on se met
ensemble un rituel ride et le soir on a
des fêtes grand fait avec la musique
haricots la nourriture comme de gambo ça
sert à ça c'est quelque chose créée au
luxembourg mais ça vient originalement
d'afrique et ça existe toujours en
afrique on a d autre chose qui vient du
petit de la france mais ça change et ça
il va arriver on à l'elysée en dix mois
nous a changés combat les tuent fait un
sens pic entre les choses comme ça tous
les sens nous ôtons queen c'est comme
les français mais c'est différent parce
que c'est touchés par les africains à sa
changé
qu'est ce que vous aimez dans la musique
malienne 11e bien moi j'aime bien le
rythme de la musique j'aime la langue
créole aussi ce qui est chanté en créole
oui je chante en créole et français
le français le oui mais ça c'est la
cohésion mais la musique était
fondée avec le violon avec les bois avec
leur mère cap et les mains les pieds à
chanter à la maison comme ça mais après
les allemands ils sont venus avec
l'accordéon c'est comme ça le monde doit
on a commencé à jouer de l'accordéon
c'est sur les animaux qui ont amené
l'accordéon oui tous les français avant
mais nous accueillons une autre qualité
c'était c'était le monde allemand qui
sont venus avec l'accordéon et voilà il
est particulier votre accordéon qui va
l'accordéon qu'on connaît le gourou
accordéon petit accordéon avec un ranger
parce que celui là on a deux rangées
tiwa ça fait on peut jouer pis à des
blues comme ça plus de nos mails
inquiéter longtemps passé il avait un
petit aquarium comme ça seulement un
ranger c'est comme ça de la musique ça a
commencé avec un petit bouc qui
s'appelle amédée ardouin et c'était un
petit bouc noir avec un homme blanc qui
s'appelle
bini smaghi dennis maigri était un bon
gardien et les deux là ils sont créés la
belle musique et ses concerts où
j'habite nous les musiciens
d'aujourd'hui nous on adore on a appris
la musique d heureusement d'armes et des
dîners smaghi comment expliquer que
cette musique soit aussi dans ce sens et
à conjurer ses confrères en contente
parce qu'ils ont louisiane c'était la
vie n'était pas facile pour le monde
n'avait l'escalavage les acadiens qu'ils
ont dû c'est pour ça que c'est une
musique aussi gai pour cent des gens un
peu joyeux dans leur vie difficiles
qu'ils avaient parce qu'il est mon ni
travaillé toute la semaine et couper la
canne et tout mais tous les samedis
soirs c'était pour les catholiques
spécialement pour les catholiques ils
mettaient ensemble ils avaient les
balles des maisons bal des maisons qui
connaît il dansait dans la maison
n'avait le grand mot et tout mais
aujourd'hui c'est plus c'est quelque
chose un truc dans les bars
voulait nous faire un extrait c'est vrai
allez vous sentez jeunes en créole et
français louise la naissance est une
chanson qui s'appelle tea blacks parce
que l'entente passée les les noirs
étaient pas permis d'être des eaux n'est
pas permis de sortir la maison le soir
parce que c'était pas permis du tout
jusqu'à les années 60 a fait cette
chanson sachant du ca
on
dit black beauty black soul et après
coucher
cet extrait on le sent c'est une musique
de lutte aussi oui il ya un message
aussi il ya un message des fois mais
normalement c'est juste c'est une
histoire de l'amour de la tristesse mais
c'est tout le temps comme ça la
tristesse l'amour le travail
du bois ray tout ça vous vivez toujours
en louisiane bien sûr la fayette à la
fayette si je vous demande comment va la
louisiane parce que la gouvernance
surtout dans beaucoup entendu parler en
france après l'ouragan katrina en 2005
avec les dégâts ils montrent que ça a
fait
beaucoup mieux que moi j'ai vu que le
monde louisiane et ils sont beaucoup
comme les haïtiens il ya un tas de
choses car il y en a dix ans qu'on est
les nombreux dons et tout ça ça passe ça
oui tous les villages et tout mais
devrait après le monde on peut continuer
on peut continuer nos vies nous autres
on peut on peut danser quand même si
grand marat les morts le jour avant on
peut continuer et c'est comme ça en
louisiane c'est un peu différent que les
autres états la louisiane c'est
ce et festive de mon île m ilham
célébrer la vos consoles espoirs 1 oui
c'est vrai beaucoup et le monde facebook
où ils ont beaucoup ensemble là bas et
blanc sens du
terme imité
merci à vous d'être venu sur le plateau
pour parler de ce festival cage à merci
beaucoup à cédric pour votre extrait
musical je rappelle donc ce festival du
6 au 10 juin un joueur pro chartrain un
démo cédric peut-être en créole comment
on peut dire bienvenue au festival en
cuir et en créole bienvenue au festival
s'est
déroulé aussi les avait pas volés mais
le connais mieux libyenne
c'est en tout cas moi je sentais que
c'est gratuit en journée et
payant et le soir c'est un terrain
gratuit en journée à partir de longueur
et payant le soir à 20 heures dans la
salle au foyer rural de pontchartrain
sinon c'est gratuit en journée donc
c'est vraiment l'occasion d'aller
écouter cette musique et de découvrir
cette culture si particulière merci
beaucoup à vous deux allez on va partir
maintenant du côté du conservatoire des
arts de montigny le bretonneux pour une
exposition qui se déroule jusqu'au 14
juin
une cinquantaine d'artistes amateurs
exposent leurs oeuvres au public
jusqu'au 14 mai au conservatoire des
arts à montigny le bretonneux rendez
vous incontournable de la saison
culturelle de la ville le salon des arts
présente des oeuvres techniques
artistiques et plus diverses quatre
grandes séries seront représentées cette
année peinture aquarelle sculpture et
photographie
vraiment le salon des arts a pour but de
montrer que quel que soit son niveau on
peut présenter son travail on peut venir
se confronter au regard du public
de façon plus ou moins modestes donc
c'est vrai qu'il ya des gens qui vont
déjà avoir un parcours très intéressant
très poussée puis d'autres qui vont
venir une fois de temps en temps où tous
les ans présentait un nouveau travail
avait forcément parfois un format un peu
plus modeste mais qui ont la volonté de
venir se confronter au regard du public
au regard des professionnels ou regard
des passants regardent et enfants regard
d'un peu tout toutes les personnes en
fait ils vont passer ici pour célébrer
cette 26e édition le salon met à
l'honneur le photographier ni mon teint
christian lopez quintas anciens
participants récompensé de nombreuses
fois pour ses oeuvres
ans
le salon des arts et compensera chacune
des catégories à l'occasion de la
cérémonie de remise des prix le 14 juin
pour l'heure les visiteurs sont invités
à élire leurs coups de coeur et cette
année les plus jeunes pourront également
décerné un prix du jeune public
le secours populaire des yvelines
organise des baptêmes de bmx pour les
enfants du vélodrome au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'occasion d'ouvrir à tous un équipement
prestigieux sensations garanties pour
les jeunes cyclistes olivier maniscalco
patrick facteur x men
des enfants sur la piste des grands
depuis le 7 mai le secours populaire des
yvelines organise des baptêmes gratuits
pour des enfants défavorisés de 6 ans et
plus sur le terrain bmx du vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines on
comprend bien milieu de virage tout en
pédalant on arrive assez vite devant la
presse et puis après on laisse aller
à plat à des séances d'initiation
encadré par un professionnel qui
permettent aux plus jeunes de découvrir
les sensations d'une structure
d'habitude réservé aux athlètes de haut
niveau
l'eso ouais surtout quand on saute et ça
faisait des sensations là qu'est ce que
ça fait comme sensation ça fait des
choses au ventre
ça fait des chansons que tu voles en
cours c'est bien et il n'y a plus de
sous c'est plus réaliste des bus arrive
et il pense même pas qu'ils sont
capables de poids de pouvoir descendre
la butte de départ se mettre un petit
objectif et passe une étape même si
certains enfants possèdent déjà un vélo
les qualités d'une telle piste de bmx le
resterai en temps normal inaccessible le
secours populaire permet donc à ces
jeunes cyclistes d'abandonner pour une
bonne heure le bitume et les trottoirs
de leur quartier
financièrement la possibilité de d'avoir
forcément en vélo chez eux et puis le
bmx est un sport assez
et moins agressive encore que le vélo
des équipes d'aidé et ont du coup c'est
vrai que le pouvoir le faire en plus sur
une piste où s'entraîne l'équipe de
france c'est d'autant plus intéressant
pour les gamins remercieront chez les
gamins qui sont venus il voulait plus
partir du coup c'est la radio pure et
trois autres baptêmes bmx sont encore
prévues le 25 juin et les 16 et 23
juillet
alors je vais maintenant vous proposer
une dégustation d'insectes banon nous ne
sommes pas du côté d'une plage de koh
lanta mais plutôt du côté de l'accueil
les yvelines un sujet signé matt hill de
capvern
ils sont repoussant voir répugnant
grillon ou vers de farine déshydraté il
nous donne pourtant envie d'y goûter une
expérience gustative unique mise au
point par un chef d'entreprise romain
fessard pionnier dans les insectes
comestibles
son but faire découvrir les bestioles
consommables au plus grand nombre on
pense que sérieusement que c'est
l'alimentation de demain et qu'il est
temps de faire goûter aux gens dans des
produits qu'on a voulu assez attractif
en proposant une sélection d'insectes de
qualité qui sont assez jolis comme les
grillons et les vers de farine avec en
plus des aromates les grilles ont un
goût de noisette qui est très léger mais
un petit goût de noisette les vers de
farine nature naturelles ont un goût de
chips au poulet sauce barbecue
thaïlandaise ou curry l'insecte se
cuisine avec tous il se retrouve aussi
en sucre et de quoi plaire aux
consommateurs tout ce qui est petit
encore ça va aller mais tout ce qui est
gros spéciale je sais pas en quoi
faut que ça rentre quand même
c'est vraiment trop grand ces tombes des
petites pizzas en un peu rose sera se
mange très bien très à gauche très bon
ça va changer un peu des cacahuètes et
chips vous pouvez les mettre un apéritif
un petit peu bien sûr justement on est
venu pour ça on va faire un apéritif on
va vider au maximum de copains copines
pour justement leur faire goûter et puis
les faire crier bien sûr l'intérêt est
avant tout écologique les insectes
consomment beaucoup moins d'énergie
d'eau et prennent moins de place que les
bovins par exemple les petites bêtes
sont elles alors l'avenir de l'homme
selon notre spécialiste
elles ne remplaceront pas totalement la
viande
et puis avant de nous quitter voici
l'agenda de cette fin de semaine alors
tout d'abord le scarabée de la verrière
qui propose ses envols un tremplin
ouvert à tous les groupes du département
avec un mot d'ordre chanter en français
et je vous propose d'ailleurs de
découvrir une compilation des artistes
présents ces trois jours une très belle
programmation signé samuel denis le
directeur des lieux
aux fenêtres
ok
non ce
faire
une balance les ouvriers
il
enferme
une rapide
d'activité
mais la pille on se sont envolés
au tableau s'est décrochée
clic
encore
aujourd'hui
ja
sans mal à l'aise
fema malice elle est très jolie ex-héros
raid sont issus rock se sent petit bruit
j'ai vendu ma vieille opel kadett j'ai
pris un méchant retour aux pensions sur
internet
qu'ils ont appris à moi dire du
en retire
retenue
juste je prenais ça
la gueule de terrain
à ces jeunes ou john lennon
pas foutu de jouer kay hian
elle s'en fout
fou d'elle
ans vit à djidji coeur
à les autres festival escales d'ailleurs
à plaisir ce sera ce samedi sur le thème
de la méditerranée
et cela se passe au château donc de
plaisir c'est un festival entièrement
gratuit dans l'impro à la ferme du
mousseau à elancourt à la compagnie
d'improvisation théâtrale déclic théâtre
présente ce vendredi son quintet d'impro
un spectacle ou cinq comédiens
improvisent sur des thèmes que le public
choisira ça promet pour le jeune public
et quitte ea propose un spectacle
interactif samedi à dix secteurs
également à la ferme du mousseau à
elancourt la ronde des orgues fait étape
ce samedi à 19 heures en l'église saint
germain de magny les hameaux un voyage
baroque coeur de l'italie qui pages
sports un gala de boxe ou une palette de
sports de combat sera présenté ce samedi
cela se passe au gymnase de l'aviation à
guyancourt et puis on finit avec un
atelier de permaculture c'est à magny
les hameaux voilà quelques idées pour
occuper votre week-end un week-end que
je vous souhaite évidemment excellent
sous le soleil a très vite